How's all the working from home thing going for you?
What?
No!
This is not good!
So, Project Pandora's Box is back and we need to present new designs on Monday.
Oh, and it needs to be recyclable.
Project Pandora's Box is back!
What?
No!
We can't do this in one meeting!
It's just a box.
But we're working from home, Bridget!
And then tomorrow, we think inside the box!
Come on, no one has anything?
Come on, we should see the solution that's lightweight and sustainable...
...and cheap.
Good morning!
Great work everybody; we are really making progress.
Oh shoot, Vivienne is calling.
Two things: the presentation has been moved to this Friday and...
Friday?
I have to take this.
What was the second thing?
I think I found the solution to the budget.
What?
How?
We make the pattern bigger.
Who's changing the design?
I thought I could do it with a little more zing.
I was reading that "TEAM" means...
..."Together, everyone achieves more."
And that...
Should we tell her she's on mute?
Not yet.
Wait!
Was I on mute?
Good, good.
Oh, wait, the client is coming on!
Is everyone wearing pants?